après le banquet de yukio mishima paraît
chez gallimard
monsieur renaudot vous êtes le
traducteur de mishima qui est mishima
depuis la mort et son atout du célèbre
hôtel is a key qui avait été candidat au
prix nobel bruno jarry et c'est voir il
ya quelques mois c'est monsieur j
mishima qui est considéré en somme comme
celui qui est à la tête de l'élite des
effets 20 japonais quels sont les livres
de mishima requis sont connus jusqu'à
présent en france
malheureusement nous n'avons pas grand
chose de lui
car si en amérique et ailleurs on a
traduit beaucoup de romans de chômage
déjà considérable et bien en france il
n'est reconnu que par un roman qui a eu
une certaine célébrité
le pavillon d'or héroïne de après le
banquet est une femme d'affaires
propriétaire d'un grand restaurant de
tokyo
elle épouse un ancien diplomate qui
tentent de revenir sur la scène
politique
le drame entre ces deux êtres reflète
l'antinomie d2 japon accès l'un sur la
tradition l'autre sur l'avenir et nous
avons le privilège d'avoir monsieur
mishima parmi nous c'est à lui
maintenant que je vais poser des
questions monsieur mishima
y at-il de littérature japonaise l'une
traditionnelle et l'autre moderne
il n'y a pas opposition entre les deux
tendances la littérature japonaise
contemporaine est une synthèse entre un
apport occidentaux importants et les
formes nationales traditionnelles
laquelle des deux tendances va tâcher ou
aux anciens ou modernes
je voudrais parler japonais attaquent
sinon quelques aura
si l'on veut définir la tendance
générale de mon oeuvre
disons qu'elle est la synthèse de
l'esthétique de la psychologie de
tradition d'ailleurs au japon esthétique
et psychologie ne sont pas deux éléments
différents l'esthétique ne s'oppose pas
non plus au réalisme
je crois que c'est une originalité au
japon il existe chez les écrivains
japonais une école à laquelle je ne
participe d'ailleurs à pas qui est celle
durement vécu qu'on appelle la haye
novel il s'agit d'une sorte de fusion de
la littérature romantique occidentale et
de la littérature confessions des moines
japonais de moyen-âge cette forme
littéraire connaît une grande vogue
depuis la fin du xixème y at il un
écrivain français qui est une influence
particulière sur vous oui raymond
radiguet que j'admire beaucoup
j'ai lu le bal de jeu celui quelle est
la situation de l'écrivain japonais dans
la société contemporaine
la situation de l'écrivain japonais à
l'époque d'alexandre dumas les mises au
jeu
les japonais sont longtemps restés
fidèles à cette forme de roman publié en
feuilleton par les journaux il ya dix
ans encore il était courant de voir de
grands journaux tient à 5 millions
d'exemplaires publié des romans de
qualité en fuite
quelle est l'influencé de la télévision
dans la vie de l'écrivain japonais est
pour lui un nouveau moyen d'expression
[Musique]
de nos jours la classe moyenne au japon
est très influencé par la télévision est
la tendance donné sa préférence au
spectacle
télévisé tout cas la ligue malgré tout
cette formule du feuilleton est
tellement enracinée dans les esprits que
les écrivains continuent à publier
d'abord le roman dans les revues
littéraires
est ce que le problème d'hiroshima pour
nous écrivains est extrêmement difficile
à aborder
il demeure au fond de notre coeur comme
un sentiment personnel profond comme un
abîme pendant quelques années après la
fin de la guerre des romanciers
d'hiroshima
mais d'un point de vue politique
d'autres auteurs vont raconter leurs
expériences personnelles sous la forme
d'un remonte biographie 15 un labo on a
commencé à voir apparaître des oeuvres
d'imagination abordant le sujet d'un
point de vue plus objectif je me permets
de vous citer l'exemple de mormant la
belle étoile
actuellement le romancier ydouna publie
un livre consacré à la bombe sous la
forme je ne fais d'hiroshima mortes dans
la catastrophe atomique
c'est un bon roman est écrit dans un
esprit extrêmement objectif merci
monsieur mishima
je rappelle que nous venons de parler
d'eux après le banquet de
[Musique]